okay have you guys seen any procedures
or policies put in place to put more
female leadership in place where you
work
[Music]
think about it and I was like oh well at
my workplace I'm a senior waitress which
is like head wait waitress or way taught
in in the front house of front of house
there's other women that also um have
well there's another lady should I say
that is also a head waitress as well but
apart from that it smells and just
smells and there's any other one female
manager and I believe that she's being
combated by two other males so are you
even relevant we're not sure but um I
just feel like
women are given are being given more um
positions but I'll be being trusted with
the positions that we've been given
that's the problem imagine giving me a
job and you've um employed me knowing
that this is the um this is my
experience and then still somehow
questioning my experience it's like do
you not know what you employed me for
did they employ you or whoever it was
because they were a woman or because
they were qualified
um I feel like they employed employed me
myself because they needed someone to be
like off that level of you know
experience in Calabar in their
establishment and they had a lot of male
counterparts already so they wanted to
even out and obviously I'm black and you
know the hierarchy you know you have to
have like gender fluid was it to fill a
quota I feel like yeah there was make
you know filling out the stuff but at
the same time they needed it to be in
the hierarchy they really had a Mel one
so it was like to even out but like I
said them giving me that position for me
felt like okay they're trying to make it
more fluid to the other ladies there
that okay you know it's possible because
I feel like before they employed me that
was something they could have given it
in like you know pay rise they could
have gave them a you know a little job
rise whatever but they didn't they put a
new person there so at times yeah I feel
like women are being given extra you
know position but just I'll be being
trusted with the position that we've
been given okay what about you
um they want to hear you speak
um what was the question again um oh
have there were there any policies put
into place to put women in more
leadership positions where you work
um the last job that I had like actual
nine to five
um one girl wanted to go as a business
manager but they made her work for it
for about two years and they kept giving
it to other men while she was waiting
for it so I feel like it's less chance
that you're gonna get a higher position
as a woman because of the things that we
discuss so no policies
the talents like there weren't any where
I was no and there wasn't it was
history it's not really it's not really
applied to me because I work for myself
and I've only worked for the one woman
so I'm not sure but Cleo I'm sure has
in short yes I feel very blessed where I
work they do open it up for different
Creeds colors ages demographics and they
like to have a 50 50 gender split within
our meetings and Leadership and they try
to um okay they try to make it 50 50.
okay go ahead
her mic I think is muted blessing
um yep on okay I think with my previous
one it's it was a thing where like in
meetings we did talk a lot about okay
when the next event happens we need more
female leaders to speak up and like kind
of take control a bit more so it's not
as male dominated so yeah I think it's
getting a bit more evened out okay
um so what they were specifically trying
to get women in yeah so in a lot of the
meetings they would say yeah we want a
lot more females to speak up like when
we do events and whatnot so yeah okay
um but let's start on that side or um
China go and then anywhere you've worked
have they tried to put policies in place
to get more women yeah in the past I've
um because yeah in the film and security
industry they've tried to get women into
more
um insecurity yeah in the film because
not represented enough you need to have
a certain amount of women women there
yeah
but it's not yeah yeah yeah
I have a I have a friend yeah yeah man
can't search woman so obviously women
obviously like if it's scenario in a
woman's toilet or something like that
you need you need to have women's
security yeah it doesn't mean they're
going to do the same thing that men are
gonna do you'll be surprised oh you're
at the search okay
yeah okay
um go ahead
um like I said I'm not that experienced
in like the working industry but it's
always been 50 50. okay there's always
women and men so okay
are there any policies in place I've
never been aware I've heard that there
are some but I've never been nowhere
okay yeah I'm very limited also okay any
policies that were put in place policies
must be invisible I ain't seen it I
ain't seen them pearly I don't know
maybe they're in the back I haven't seen
them
um go ahead
um in my industry of work
um they mainly
employ or women mainly apply for like go
forward for those roles so if anything
it's about equality and diversity so
evening out and looking for men
potentially okay
um because there are policies put into
place to put women in leadership can we
say there's anything holding women back
from doing any job in 2022
no okay no kids
yeah okay what about you guys who said
yeah I'm answered yeah but I'll say I'm
personal life choices I feel like what
you want to do in your life and where
you want to go is what you will
fluctuate more towards say some women
have much ambition not to say that you
know anyone's ambitionist but some
people just want to do the mainstream
they don't want to exert themselves
further or broaden the Horizon that's
what I feel okay go ahead you too
yeah I think mostly women don't really
want to do those roles because this is
like generalized because they're harder
jobs and women prefer the easier life
what was the question again exactly
sorry can we say that women are held
back from doing any job in 2022 when
there's specific policies to help women
and there's nothing stopping us from
applying from any job I was just going
to say I think if the only thing
nowadays especially like the Western
World the only thing that hold women
back is themselves maybe you know
whatever their home life is or you know
whatever limiting beliefs they have
around having such a high-paid job
yeah I
I've always done what I wanted in my
career I've always as an out of turned
every now and three years so I take it
as a challenge personally if they tell
me no then I'm like watch me yeah great
um second row girl I kind of
just
um to defend probably another side of it
sorry just adjusted the just to defend
another side of it I think maybe some
women may find it they may think it's
unattractive to another man to make more
money or be more successful so they may
not want to go for those job roles
because they may want the man to feel
like the man in the household and um
yeah making a lot of money is a skit as
a woman and having your own [ __ ] and not
needing [ __ ] much [ __ ]
um can be just hasn't can be very I've
been told
um scary or I think it's just the
attitude that comes with it I agree yeah
fairly you can come all sugary and sweet
with it and just kind of chill but some
women want to throw it in the man's face
like look at me I'm a workout I make
money my name is like if you if you're
the Breadwinners is your money his money
can you make the financial decisions or
is your money your money
um a few because like I said I but back
to my point before I trust men's
decision making as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible